Це моє захоплення. Коли твоє влучення чітко в мішень, то ти отримуєш дійсно задоволення.
Підтягуюся, як для свого класу, беручи хлопців своєї вікової групи, на п’ятірку. Мій максимум - це 15 разів.
Я не ходила ні на які секції. Активно займатися спортом я почала у військовому інституті.
Навіть не підозрюєш, що військовослужбовець!
"Спецпризначенка на підборах", капітан Нацгвардії України Ніна Дроздовська
може швидко перевтілюватися в різні образи.
Їй 27 років, і вона - одна з майже 650 жінок-офіцерів Нацгвардії.
Броня на мені - 8 700.
Звикла, нормально. Все ж таки коли хлопці під два метри зросту, то на них це добре сидить. А коли метр шістдесят, як я, то трішки великувате.
Бронежилети саме для жінок у Національній гвардії, якщо вірити заявам керівництва, в процесі замовлення ще з минулого року.
Адже попит на них уже немалий. Бути військовослужбовцем для Ніни було мрією ще з дитинства.
Вона росла на розповідях свого дядька, який служив ще в старій Нацгвардії.
Потім прикладом став її брат, який теж став військовослужбовцем.
Узагалі, чому я захотіла бути нацгвардійкою - я закінчила виш Збройних сил.
Але коли випускалися з інституту, Нацгвардії був тільки рік, вона тільки сформувалася.
І мені захотілося піти в НГУ так, як у маленьку таку  династію.
Я дуже горіла - проводити час десь на якихось полігонах, виїздах.
Можливо, бачили фільм "Солдатка Джейн"? Я якраз в школі його дивилася, і дана героїня мене дуже надихала.
І мені хотілося бути сильною, відважною і цілеспрямованою, як вона.
Ніна  має дві освіти. Військову - за спеціальністю зв’язківця.
І цивільну - вона тренерка зі стрільби, володіє різними видами зброї.
Служить вона у Міжнародному міжвідомчому центрі спеціальних дій,
де вітчизняні та іноземні інструктори проводять спеціальні навчання.
5 патронів у першому магазині. Обов’язково одна перезарядка.
Звичайно, всі перезарядки йдуть від укриття до укриття.
Ще питання? На вогневий рубіж!
Ніна за контрактом - інструкторка зі стрільби. І навчає вона еліту Нацгвардії - бійців підрозділів спеціального призначення.
Ось у нас були навчання…  нещодавно заїжджав курс снайперів.
І я як інструкторка повинна була навчати їх стрільбі з пістолету.
Це були мої перші заняття. Трішки було боязко. Не знала, як будуть реагувати.
Але я дуже здивувалася, що коли вказувала на якісь помилки, десь я трішки виправляла,
всі розуміли і досить спокійно реагували і слухалися, і навіть підходили, запитували деякі  уточнення.
Ці чоловіки за плечима мають досвід багатьох бойових операцій.
Проте як військовослужбовці повинні постійно вдосконалювати свої навички.
У Нацгвардії, яка існувала в Україні до 2003 року, жінок на посадах інструкторок майже не було.
У новоствореній з 2014-го року Нацгвардії жінки - вже давно не виняток з правил.
Спочатку було незвично. Сприймаєш жінку-інструкторку як шкільну вчительку, але з часом звикаєш.
Жінок з часом стає дедалі більше на різних посадах. Раніше були зв’язківці та психологи. А зараз це інструктори, командири взводів є.
Тому я гадаю, що це тільки на краще. Жінка більш відповідальна.
Коли з вами на вправі, то вона стежить за тим, щоб ви чітко виконували цю вправу, щоб ви не порушували заходи безпеки,
тому що вона більш відповідальна.
Нині Ніна - не єдина жінка-інструкторка, є ще її колега - старша сержант.
Гендерні зміни, за словами керівника Центру підготовки до спеціальних дій, полковника Костянтина Корніцького,
крок за кроком змінюють Нацгвардію. Усього в Нацгвардії нині працює і служить майже 5 з половиною тисяч жінок.
Поки найменша їхня кількість - серед спецпризначенців.
За словами полковника, за 4 роки існування центру тут навчалися лише 20 жінок з таких підрозділів.
Наприклад, якщо брати один із загонів спецпризначення Західної України НГУ, там є військовослужбовець-жінка,  яка
за своєю фаховою спеціальністю може дати фору в принципі військовослужбовцям-чоловікам свого підрозділу.
Вона не потребує будь-якої допомоги і рівноцінно переносить  як фізичні, так і психологічні навантаження.
У підрозділі спецпризначення немає різниці між чоловіками та жінками.
Усі мають мати відповідну фізпідготовку і, як тут кажуть, кмітливість.
Вчитися нелегко, і цей дзвін інколи лунає, коли хтось не витримав.
Ніна не з тих, хто здається.
Я зараз інструкторка. Я хочу розвиватися і йти далі. І, можливо, в майбутньому бути серед спрецпризначенців.
Я рівняюся на хлопців все ж таки і намагаюся робити ті нормативи, які вони роблять.
Жінка постійно тренується, займається крос-фітом, регулярними пробіжками,
бойовим самбо, пройшла базовий курс самозахисту, планує пройти курс ножового бою тощо.
Молода жінка серед військовослужбовців-чоловіків... Наскільки це безпечно?
Ніна Дроздовська запевняє, що досі не зіштовхувалася з проблемами на кшталт сексизму чи домаганнями.
Знаки уваги - це за парканом! Тут ми всі військовослужбовці і повинні дотримуватися порядку і статуту.
Якісь знаки я не приймаю. Усі військові розуміють, що є служба, а є цивільне життя і всі відносини.
Якби ж щось подібне і сталося, вона чітко знає алгоритм дій:
рапорт керівництву,  службова перевірка і у разі підтвердження фактів, загроза кримінальної відповідальності -
відповідно до нових законів, що були ухвалені в Україні торік.
Гучні секс-скандали в Національній гвардії поки не траплялися.
Керівництво Ніни Дроздовської запевняє, що такого тут не потерплять: ні з боку чоловіків, ні з боку жінок.
У Нацгвардії впроваджуються стандарти НАТО, за якими кількість жінок-військовослужбовців має постійно збільшуватися.
Чотири роки тому була створена служба гендерної інтеграції, завдання якої
зробити усе можливе задля забезпечення рівних прав та можливостей жінок та чоловіків.
Капітан Дроздовська каже, що це додає психологічного комфорту на службі в Нацгвардії
і мотивує рухатися далі по кар’єрній драбині.
При цьому жінка в армії не мусить назавжди розпрощатися зі своєю жіночністю.
Скидає форму, одягає плаття, гарний макіяж, і вона - жінка! Навіть не підозрюєш, що вона - військовослужбовець.
Ніна спостерігає, як змінюється не лише військова служба, а й суспільство в бік гендерної рівності.
Навіть діти, до яких вона ходила розповідати про Нацгвардію, вже інакше ставляться до жінок у формі,
ніж в її дитинстві, коли подібного взагалі не бачили.
Каже, що чимало маленьких дівчат завалили її питаннями, як вона стала гвардійкою та що їм потрібно для цього зробити.
Сучасна жінка, за словами Ніни має працювати не лише над зовнішністю, а й над фізичними здібностями.
Не завжди буде чоловік поряд чи той же брат або хлопець.
Я дуже рада, коли жінки ідуть на самозахист.
Фізична підготовка - це не тільки краса зовнішня, це і її захист.
У якийсь момент це може врятувати їй життя.